he's threatening the [ __ ] follow soul
again on Instagram yeah so lose night my
ex-boyfriend who asked you this guy's
asked a question yes
so if she has an ex-boyfriend or
somebody she used to see am I not
allowed to follow them on its no
absolutely why though
look at me Gilbert why I would say it's
okay to fall if he's not bothered by it
tell you why him cuz he made fun of you
for dating me in the beginning in the
beginning yes yeah
oh and there's beef there yes so I think
I'm allowed to follow him but why would
you follow the goose not to cut you is
that the guy from it that the guy put
him I don't [ __ ] that [ __ ] combo
ye in the his dumb oven you know Spanish
friend haha and then when he got hurt
and he who had to retire from soccer I
laughed for two [ __ ] straight days so
good he called he made fun of you you
made fun of me
alright what's he doing now oh I don't
know he know he threads you know me that
the soccer balls he's soccer ball
threader oh oh it's handmade soccer
balls either a soccer ball yeah he's
artisanal what is he gonna do not play
song yeah but you can't follow him I
think I don't think that's just socially
the right move
do you follow any of my exes of course
not
sarah hyland have you google horse how
you google them ever if I met her and I
think she seems like a nice girl and we
were friends yes that would probably I
would follow her then Christine of
course not now if I met her and we
became friends then yes yeah but for no
[ __ ] reason out of nowhere that's
just [ __ ] weird yeah okay so don't do
it you don't do it you don't do what
you're doing
he thread soccer balls you don't do what
you're doing as of late thank you okay
you game [ __ ] sex eyes to everybody
you don't do what you're doing I won't
do what I'm doing yep okay
[Music]